si vous avez croisé une de ses voitures
dans la rue c'était un examen au permis
de conduire
les sessions sont maintenues même si les
auto écoles sont fermées ne peuvent plus
dispensés de cours en fait au moment où
j'ai voulu reprendre des heures bayel
consumant qui est tombé donc voilà j'ai
dû venir à l'examen sans me préparer au
préalable nous partons en examen là ce
matin on a rendez-vous à 10h et on a
quatre candidats à présenter donc on a
des candidats qui n'ont pas conduit
depuis un mois et demi deux mois pour
certains une situation délicate pour
certains qui se confrontent à
l'inspecteur sans se sentir vraiment
prêt j'étais très stressé dans la
voiture et je pense que ça s'est vu que
j'avais pas conduit depuis un moment
donc
alors moi j'ai de la chance puisque je
suis en conduite supervisée donc j'ai pu
conduire avec ma famille récemment donc
aidé à la fois que j'ai pu conduire
c'était il ya une semaine et demie de
semaine
c'est quand même assez léger comme
entraînement donc c'est pour ça que
j'étais chanceux d'avoir un rendez vous
assez tôt pour éviter de perdre un peu
encore plus la main pour pour l'examen
les épreuves sont maintenues pour
désengorger au maximum les demandes
certains élèves attendre leur session
depuis plusieurs semaines le bouchon qui
s'est créé sur le premier confinement
c'est surtout ça qui coince donc l'idée
c'est de
maintenir les examens pour pas accentuer
le problème de files d'attentes pour les
délais de présentation
je pense qu'ils animeront pas c'est ça
le plus le mois de novembre avancent
plus le temps est long entre un candidat
et sa dernière heure de conduite
c'est pourquoi les taux de réussite des
écoles ne devraient pas être prises en
compte pendant la période